[Music]
every 24 hours wind generates enough
kinetic energy to produce roughly 35
times more electricity than humanity
uses each day
and unlike kohler oil this resource is
totally renewed each day
so how can we harness this incredible
amount of energy and is it possible to
create a world powered entirely by wind
the basic principle of wind energy is
simple a series of sails or blades
mounted around a rotor catch the wind
and translate its kinetic energy into
rotational energy traditional windmills
use that rotational energy to grind
wheat or pump water but in modern wind
turbines it turns a generator that
creates electricity
this conversion from wind to rotational
energy to electricity has defined wind
turbines since their invention in the
late 19th century
and there are three primary factors that
determine just how much energy they can
produce
the size and orientation of the blades
the blade's aerodynamic design and the
amount of wind turning the rotor
first up blade orientation
wind turbines can be designed with their
rotor on a vertical axis or a horizontal
axis
vertical blades can pick up wind coming
from any direction but with much less
efficiency than horizontal axis rotors
horizontal designs allow blades to
capture the winds full force by tracking
the wind's direction and turning to face
it this turning process is called yawing
and older windmills achieved it through
manual monitoring
today wind sensors and computer systems
automatically adjust the blades with
expert precision to capture as much
energy as possible
outside rotor orientation the blades
themselves need to be shaped to maximize
efficiency while early designs used flat
blades modern blades are curved like
airplane wings wind travels faster over
the curved surface creating a low
pressure pocket above the blade that
forces it upwards
since the amount of lift depends on the
angle at which the wind is moving
relative to the blade modern blades also
incorporate a twist
optimizing how much of the blade can cut
into the wind
made of fiberglass and resin layers
these blades are strong enough to
operate through rain lightning and
blistering sunlight for over 20 years
even with aerodynamic blades and a
horizontal rotor a wind turbine can only
capture wind if it's in a windy
environment
wind speeds typically increase the
higher into the atmosphere you travel
so today most turbines are well over 100
meters tall with equally large rotor
diameters
a turbine of this height and size can
capture a huge amount of wind generating
enough electricity every year to power
750 american homes
a wind farm of 200 similarly sized
turbines could power over 150 000
american homes or twice as many european
homes for an entire year
offshore wind farms contain an even
greater number of even larger turbines
in 2019 the largest wind turbine ever
built began operating off the coast of
the netherlands with a rotor diameter of
220 meters just one of these turbines
can meet the annual power needs of
sixteen thousand european households
despite its amazing potential wind
energy still faces challenges
wind may be a free and unlimited fuel
but no matter how large or efficient a
turbine is there's a mathematical limit
to how much wind it can convert into
electricity
german physicist albert betts calculated
that since some wind must remain to keep
the blades spinning a turbine can only
ever capture 59.3
of the wind's energy
additionally some people feel turbines
disrupt natural scenery and wind
energy's intermittent availability can
make it difficult to integrate into
electrical grids
but even with these challenges modern
wind turbines have made wind energy the
most efficient and inexpensive source of
electricity
wind turbines already provide essential
energy for communities around the world
and for many farmers hosting a wind
turbine can be a reliable source of
additional income
with continued improvements in wind
forecasting electrical grid
infrastructure and energy storage wind
power might blow away all our energy
problems
next up learn how solar energy works or
if you're more of a big picture person
explore whether we could power our world
with a hundred percent renewable energy
[Music]
you